[Music]
we were gonna have you on the on the
first the first week we were gonna have
you on the first week but then you you
went and got married yeah which I grew
up yeah do you remember on my podcast
you railed for about 30 hilarious
minutes against marriage like the most
persuasive never get married it's a
racket they're gonna take half your [ __ ]
that why at this point no that's true
[Laughter]
absolutely insane thing to do yes gay or
straight yes they have no idea what
they're walking into
I can't wait I don't I don't wish this
on anybody one but when the gay divorces
start coming in that they're really
gonna step back I think being like what
the hell did will we wish him for him I
could have sent him a card on his
deathbed
I can't go say goodbye when they're
dying but that's if you make it but it's
literally like as far as marriage is
working that's like the sperm making it
to the egg yeah Jersey dude it's facts
most of them don't work and you got to
start all over again just bust it you
know yeah I don't know how it's gonna
work
with because it usually sides for the
women but when you got two dudes like
houses how is that gonna work out right
you know what I'm saying I guess it
works out for whoever's making more
money this is classic like how I talk on
the podcast like just get into it oh hey
I'm a [ __ ] and I didn't read up on this
how is that gonna work up well god yeah
it's gonna work the gang dude who's not
doing [ __ ] is gonna get all the stuff
and be like oh I'm used to a certain
lifestyle right and then the gay guy was
killing it he's gonna go back to the
studio apartment calling it right now
right now so you're gonna be great it'll
bring straights and gays closer together
just start like a divorce bar like all
people welcome and just compare notes
like what's more horrific of a bitter ex
dude or a bitter ex woman yeah when they
wrote that hell hath no fury like a
woman scorned there weren't as many
public gay relationships so maybe maybe
that's real bad too
yeah but they didn't have the right to
try they think not being married they
didn't have a legal contract right so I
think what that when they broke up was
probably whoever was stronger you know
they just sort of rest stuff you guys
are taking this really seriously
okay people break up I'm just messing
around
he introduced me as a comedian I'm not
gonna go on split screen with a blogger
tomorrow
comedy can it go too far home show right
there with you I have to think that's a
feature of a gay relationship is there
would be more wrestling to settle things
oh yeah but is that like is that spousal
abuse or did you just get your ass
kicked
you know enemy
[Applause]
let's roast and less punching of walls
right above heads very dark I'm with you
brother you gotta go with the liver shot
your groans are feeding me if your fault
[Music]